it's the first time television is being
shown at this scale clearly having Game
of Thrones in imax is a game changer and
it's thrilling to be a part of that
there's such a thrill the prospect of it
being on imax we always were so inspired
by at victims you know this is a quieter
time of year for feature releases and
we've often looked for a unique content
to fill this period and this is such a
natural fit when you see the production
value the quality of content that's
happening on Game of Thrones it's just
great to give the department heads
chance to really strut their stuff and
show off what they've been doing I was
looking at elements of the hounds
costume their armor that I just never
noticed before the stuff that really
lives and breathes and I Max's stuff
with scale and scope they deliver on
that every episode you know it's very
hard to get a full sense of that on the
TV screen the vistas are so amazing so
to see those spaces whether they're the
real world spaces or the beautiful sets
that's huge hbl will deliver to us some
of the raw picture elements and the raw
sound elements that we deploy our DMR
set of tools on the DMR is really about
optimizing picture and sound for
presentation in imax
they clean up noise grain they sharpen
the image that looked as good as
anything you'd see in high-end visual
effects in the film the sound system in
an IMAX theater is quite unique and I
think the score is really gonna resonate
with the audience having the show come
from a small TV screen to a big I max
screen is amazing to get that kind of
exposure and have that sound missed
hearing remains beautiful score coming
at you from all angles blasting at you
from those amazing speakers at the
volume frankly it was really meant to be
heard
really kept just a full spectrum of the
sound you get the high you get too low
all the different frequencies speak in
the way that I really hadn't heard
before you feel the action and you're
right in the middle of it fully immersed
with IMAX this feels like you're being
thrust into the middle of one of these
immersive imax documentaries seeing all
of this come together at the same time
you know as we sit here in this golden
age of television I've never seen it on
the screen like that game of thrones and
imax it's going to blow the roof off